donald trump managed to tell
eight lies about the election in just a
handful of tweets overnight and i do
mean overnight
and it was a bizarre evening for donald
trump
uh his presidency is entering the tenth
to last
week of his presidency spreading
disinformation
retweeting violent out of context videos
and because of his tweets i'm going to
be able to tell you three or four
different stories that i wanted to talk
about anyway so we'll use the tweets as
a sort of jumping off point
so first to reset as night had fallen i
already read this earlier i want to read
it one more time
tr and sort of uh fact check it trump
tweeting
why does the fake news media
continuously assumed that joe biden will
ascend to the presidency well because he
won
not even allowing our side to show which
we are just getting ready to do how
badly shattered and violated our great
constitution has been in the 2020
election
it was attacked perhaps like never
before that's untrue
um aside from anecdotal instances of you
know
the pennsylvania lieutenant governor
found two irregularities both involving
republicans
but it was an election that was a
relatively secure
quite secure from large numbers of poll
watchers that were thrown out of vote
counting rooms in many of our states
so that there were people who weren't
actually poll watchers who were told you
can't be in here
but every state had both republican and
democratic poll watchers as is
as is part of the rules to millions of
ballots that have been altered by
democrats
completely untrue no evidence for that
whatsoever
to using radical left owned dominion
voting
systems that's another conspiracy which
is being used to claim millions of votes
were digitally flipped to buy
no evidence of it whatsoever those
responsible for the safeguarding of our
constitution cannot allow the fake
results
of the election to stand the world is
watching well the the
the results are real and they will stand
so you know it's deceptive to attack the
media
for not pretending trump maybe once said
he didn't
uh the idea that trump doesn't get to
show his side
is a lie they've gone to courts ten
times all the courts say
there's nothing here and there are like
five lies just
to to start with right off the bat then
at midnight trump is still going he
tweets
simply i won the election now that's a
lie joe biden
won the election then trump retweeted a
bunch of nonsense including a tweet from
a random sycophant
who said have the have changed to
newsmax and oan they are so much better
this is part of trump's
new ongoing attack against fox news for
not i guess being
sycophantic enough to donald trump then
trump in the middle of the night
retweeting his own prior tweet
where he said quote antifa scum
ran for the hills today when they tried
attacking the people
at the trump rally because those people
aggressively fought back
antifa waited until tonight when 99
were gone to attack innocent mega people
dc police get going do your job and
don't hold back now
this is important trump also started
retweeting a lot of deceptive videos of
violence meant to imply
that all you saw in dc was random
trumpets walking by
on their way to do community service i'm
sure getting attacked
by left wingers um there were video
there's a guy named andy no
spelled ngo who was tweeting a bunch of
these dave
rubin a cultural critic and arbiter of
ideas dave rubin who had
an awakening that pulled him away from
liberalism towards
i guess voting trump a few years ago
they were all tweeting these videos
purporting to be of innocent trump is
getting beaten
and incredibly i even covered some of
these on my twitter
many of these videos that these
right-wingers and trump were tweeting
out
were that they were indeed of trumpists
being attacked after these same
trumpists were running
wild on the streets of dc punching
people
including women and and uh committing
what appear to be multiple different
felonies and trump continued to tweet a
lot of those trash videos all night
will trump's twitter be suspended when
trump is no longer president that's the
question when trump is no longer
president
his twitter account will no longer have
certain public person protections
one would imagine that it would be
appropriate to suspend donald trump's
twitter account at that point in time
and again i i want to go back to this
because it's so
important the most dangerous part of
this is that trump's followers believe
it
trump's followers believe joe biden
didn't win legitimately
trump's followers believe that dc was
mostly
antifa violence which it of course was
not
and it reminds us that the real danger
isn't someone like trump who says this
stuff
it's a country where 50 60 70 million of
your followers believe
anything you say to some degree or
another that's really the danger
and we'll have more coverage of this on
our instagram page
at david pakman show one of our sponsors
is hydrant which is a delicious fruit
drink powder that you
mix into water for rehydration and
they're giving you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant
immunity packed with vitamins a b c and
d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video